my name is Charlie I'm 18 years old I'm
a boy and I am afraid of lots of things
I'm afraid of commitment
I'm afraid of multitasking I'm afraid of
my little pony
I'm afraid of moths but most importantly
I'm afraid and I'm petrified of women
women scare me a lot and I've been
afraid of women pretty much my entire
life particularly in the last few years
which is probably why I haven't had a
girlfriend and up until I was about 16
years old I never really knew why I was
afraid of women I always thought that my
fear of women must have been an
irrational fear and obviously I didn't
think this is an irrational fear when I
was 2 because I didn't know what
irrational meant but then I realized
something and I know this might sound a
little bit mad which is because it is
but bear with me I'm sure a lot of you
know the saying that a woman can always
tell when a man is lying but I think it
goes a lot deeper than that I believe
that women can read minds I know it
sounds mad right but I I can prove it I
can prove it I in this video I will
prove to you that women can in fact read
minds why do women wear high heels why
do you get a better signal on your
mobile phone if you stand on a chair
it's the same principle if women are
higher up on their high heels then they
can get a better brain wave signal why
do some women wear those ridiculously
large earrings
why is satellites knightshade the
earrings are there to help them capture
those brainwaves from farther away so
that they can so that they could read
our minds why do women have longer hair
than men why do you get a better signal
on your radio if you pull out the aerial
longer longer hair better brain wave
signal we all know that women love to
gossip right could you imagine this two
women in a room with a man secretly
gossiping about that man
silently using their psychic powers have
you ever seen the Beehive haircut well
my theory is that some women have
massive brains that they can use not
only to read minds but to control minds
as well and they need that haircut to
hide their brain the massive ginormous
mutated brain it's right there women can
read minds you know as impressed as me I
can tell I know that this might seem
like random speculation but I
I do believe that this could be a
definite possibility so I have invented
something that will prove the women
definitely can read minds I've invented
this
it's called the super psychic reader
automatic the super psychic reader
automatic has two wires one of the wise
connects to my computer so that it can
give the hats power and the other wire
connects to my iPhone I open up the
super psychic reader app Ematic and I
can read brainwaves if you have a look
there then you can see that I have no
psychic reading obviously because I'm a
man but I believe that if we put this
hat on a woman we get any sort of
psychic reading on my phone then women
can definitely without any doubt read
minds and so with that it's time for me
to get a woman bride a this is my sister
hi
I'm just making your video at the moment
it's just a stupid little video and I've
got this hat but I just want you to put
on just for the video cuz I blow it
might be quite funny so can you put that
on mmm alright yeah
very dashing if you just just leap
that's that's perfect just hold it like
that for a second okay right we'll just
just leave it like that you feel
anything is that and that is fine just a
quick question right yeah um can all
women read minds
what kettle women read minds because I
kind of just like I've kind of just
proved for the internet that all women
can read minds so there's no denying it
well yeah fine all women can read minds
are you it I knew it I knew it I knew
all along I'm charlie you don't realize
what because you know this you're going
to have to die good will Charlie survive
will Bridey ever find true love will be
revealed next week here on the charlie
is so cool like web video show thingy
whatever this is